Jack Smith and his team are coming out.
So let's listen in.
Good afternoon.
Today, an indictment is unsealed
charging Donald J.
Trump with felony violations
of our national security laws,
as well as participating
in a conspiracy to obstruct justice.
This indictment was voted by a grand
jury of citizens
in the Southern District of Florida.
Now, I invite everyone to read it in full
to understand the scope
and the gravity of the crimes charged.
The men and women
of the United States
intelligence community
and our armed forces dedicate their lives
to protecting our nation and its people.
Our laws
that protect national defense information
are critical
to the safety
and security of the United States,
and they must be enforced.
Violations of those laws put our country
at risk.
Adherence to the rule of law
is a bedrock principle
of the Department of Justice,
and our nation's commitment
to the rule of law
sets an example for the world.
We have one set of laws in this country,
and they apply to everyone
applying those laws, collecting facts.
That's what determines
the outcome of an investigation.
Nothing more, nothing less.
The prosecutors in my office are among
the most talented
and experienced
in the Department of Justice.
They have investigated
this case, hewing to the highest
ethical standards,
and they will continue to do
so in this case proceeds.
It's very important for me to note
that the defendants in this case
must be presumed innocent
until proven guilty
beyond a reasonable doubt
in a court of law.
To that
end, my
office will seek a speedy trial
in this matter,
consistent with the public interest
and the rights of the accused.
We very much look forward
to presenting our case
to a jury of citizens
in the Southern District of Florida
In conclusion, I would like to thank
the dedicated public
servants of the Federal Bureau
of Investigation
with whom
my office is conducting
this investigation,
and who work tirelessly every day
upholding the rule of law in our country.
I'm deeply proud to stand shoulder
to shoulder with them.
Thank you very much.
Why that?
Why did you decide
to bring the case in Florida?
I was special counsel Jack Smith.
We knew
he wasn't going to take questions,
even though
one eager reporter
attempted there,
speaking at the Justice Department,
talking about the federal charges
facing former President Donald Trump
and one of his aides.
The indictment released this afternoon
detailing 37 charges facing Mr.
Trump, including the willful retention
of national defense information
and obstruction of justice.
Let's discuss with my panel.
And Laura Coates,
let me start with you,
because I want you to translate for us.
When Jack Smith says
that they are going to pursue
a speedy trial
pursuant to all the rights
that the accused has.
What does that mean?
How soon might this trial begin?
Well, he obviously is aware
that the Department of
Justice has a policy.
They don't want to do anything
that might interfere with an election.
We know we are 500 some days away
from the presidential election
and two months
from the first of three months
from the first debate
and of course, primaries ahead
about after as well.
He's aware of that.
And the talking point
is obviously out there.
And he tried to undermine the idea
of the adherence to the law
as a bedrock principle
and nothing else was actually the reason
to do this. He's aware of that.
And so with an eye towards that notion,
he is trying to confirm to the people
of the United States
who are hearing him right now
that they are going to do
everything that they can now.
That does not mean that the judge
or everyone else in this case
will do everything
that they can
to do this
before any of those timelines,
because as you can imagine,
if, for example, Donald Trump
somehow secures
the RNC nomination
and if he is able to become
the president,
the United States yet again
and win over the Democratic incumbent,
then that would mean that any player
would actually toll at that point.
Because now that you can no longer
continue to pursue a case
against a sitting president
based on DOJ guidelines,
and so the speed and the timing
will both be a friend and a foe of Jack
Smith and Andy McCabe.
Let me ask you,
as a former FBI
official, is it
unusual that the Justice Department
decided to release the indictment today?
And if so, why do you think they did?
Highly unusual.
The normal order is the indictment
remains sealed
until the defendant
is presented in court at the arraignment,
which we know Tuesday in Miami.
That's right.
Tuesday in Miami
about about the same time we're at today.
So that's how it normally happens.
I'm a little bit surprised
that they released it
early here
simply because
I think it would have been
in their advantage
to be able to say
we followed the normal process
with respect
to this remarkable defendant
in every possible instance.
However,
I think that DOJ capitulated in some
some respect to the enormous pressure
that's been put on them by
we in the media
and some political figures saying like,
this thing is so volatile,
people are so interested in it,
and the American people
need to see these facts today.
So that's what they did.
But this press conference, very clearly,
this was like a cover letter, right?
There was no substance here.
What Jack Smith wants us to do
is read the indictment,
and he started his comments
by saying exactly
that we have one set of laws
protecting information
for national security
sake is incredibly important.
And read the indictment.
And that's basically all you.
Dana Bash,
a lot of the Republicans
out there running for president
against Donald Trump,
with the exceptions of Chris Christie.
And these are Hutchinson,
a lot of them
running to Donald Trump's defense
You know,
and I
literally just got a text from a
veteran Republican strategist
not affiliated
with any of the presidential campaigns
saying if a candidate
can't make an effective argument
that this guy might very well be in jail.
I don't know what they can do.
Well, they probably won't.
I mean,
many of the candidates
I mean, even down to former Vice
President Mike Pence,
who you were speaking to just
a couple of days ago,
not wanting to talk about it, really
going out of his way today
to discuss
to not discuss
the substance of this case.
Pence
is not quite in the Asa Hutchinson camp,
not quite in the
maybe the Chris Sununu
or the Chris Christie camp.
But he is staking his campaign
on this
premise that Trump violated his oath
on January 6th
and should not be president again.
But he is reluctant,
it seems, at this very moment.
And that could change in the future,
but right now is reluctant
to weigh in on this case.
A lot of these candidates,
a lot of Republicans right now
probably understand
what the poll numbers have shown us over
a long period of time, which is that
at the very least,
it's probably about half of Republicans
will are willing to
or have been willing up
until this point
to give Trump a pass on this case
and on many others.
Will that change
based on this indictment?
We don't know.
But a lot of Republicans in the field
right now
are looking to see
where the wind is blowing
to determine where they go.
And not enough
time has passed as of right now.
Jamie,
I would just say beyond reluctant,
I mean, we saw Pence
come out with his announcement
and finally say these things.
On the other hand, he also said he did
not think charges
should be pursued against Trump.
Right.
No one should be above the law,
but don't do this.
So let's let's talk a little bit
about the substance. If we can.
John, we'll talk to former Governor
Asa Hutchinson later in the show.
He's actually calling for Donald Trump
to drop out of the race
because of this indictment.
I mean, when you read the indictment,
it's stunning
and it's entirely credible
because it's based on
contemporaneous notes, texts, photographs
and transcripts
and the detail in it is stunning.
And also important to note,
when you craft an indictment,
the lawyers can say this better
than I do.
You want to prove your case.
Probable cause to make the count.
There's a lot in there.
It's also a lot that's not in there.
You don't have to put it all in there.
And so what they put in there,
Trump's conversation
with his lawyers, text
messages, testimony from Mar
a Lago employees.
Again, Donald Trump
wants to make this about anything
but him
and the people around
him, that this is him
and the people around him.
I want to quickly
talk about what we just heard
from Jack Smith, though,
because we've
never heard his voice before.
He took this job
and he is now bringing a historic case
against a former president
and a current frontrunner
for the Republican nomination.
That was an economy of words,
but I think they were very important
words.
Number one,
he said Donald Trump
put our country at risk.
He's trying to break through
to all Americans,
but especially the 33, 35.
What's the number of percent of Americans
who believe anything
Donald Trump tells them?
Donald Trump says this is a box's hope.
This is casual. This is not a big deal.
That was the special counsel
saying, Donald Trump
put our country at risk,
put the men and women
in the military at risk,
put the intelligence services at risk,
and then in the end,
when he defended the work of the FBI,
that tells me he is very aware,
even though his
his job is to prove this case in court.
He understands
the political argument underway
right now.
Donald Trump has attacked the FBI
for months and months
and months and months,
but is forcefully doing so now.
And a member of the House
Republican Party, Andy Biggs,
says we are
we need to
this is the time for an eye, for an eye,
and that we have reached a war phase.
January 6th is not too far
in the rearview mirror. Yeah.
And you have people who put their hand
on a Bible
or swear an oath to the Constitution
who are now saying things I'm sorry.
Donald Trump,
as the special counsel noted,
is innocent until proven guilty.
Absolutely.
However,
the words of elected officials, leader,
official leadership
officials, people
in positions of authority
and standing in our country
are incredibly important, always,
but all the more so at this moment.
And you have these
you have Republican officials who,
even before they saw this indictment,
said these charges were baseless.
The special counsel,
his test is in a court of law,
but he was trying right there
to shake people, to say at least
please read the damn thing.
Well, and also just
I mean, an obvious note,
but Donald Trump was elected in 2016
in no small part
because he was taking issue with
Hillary Clinton's
treatment of classified documents
on her email server
Lock her up was about her recklessness
with classified information,
alleged recklessness.
To your point about the details,
you're making a great point
because look at the photographs
in that, right.
They lock her up because of the
email server.
Right.
Hundreds of documents,
maps and the military information,
nuclear information
in foreign country
and control options
it showed that
one of all the documents spilled out
that have the five eyes labeled five eyes
is the five
allies, the United States, Australia,
New Zealand, and others, UK.
And these are documents
that are only accessible, only allowable
to be seen
by people in the intelligence community
in these five countries.
And and there's a
there's a photograph
that I'm sure of our team
will find
of the documents
spilled all over the storage room
in the in a facility that is not secure.
It's the opposite of secure this
that ballroom had hundreds of events
during this period of time.
There is that it?